millions women in this country are gonna
lose their healthcare access not to
abortion services to basic family
planning
you know mammograms I do not have
mammogram machines at our health centers
and we've never stated that we did it's
almost as though you're a pathological
sociopathic serial killer with babies so
before I get to John Oliver's recent
video on crisis pregnancy centers have a
question of the day are you pro-life or
do you consider yourself pro-choice now
here's the key if it's the case that you
consider yourself pro-choice and a lot
of people do do you still at this point
kind of have to acknowledge that the
pro-choice activists today are merely
pro-abortion can we all kind of agree
that it's just assumed you're on board
with abortion the kind of laws that you
see from the DNC debbie Wasserman
Schultz you see in Colorado up to 26
weeks I mean it's it's gone a bit around
the bend it's hard to say it's
pro-choice with the kind of messaging
being pushed out so John Oliver went on
his show today or not today sorry this
weekend this is this is his latest show
to take aim at volunteer crisis
pregnancy centers now if it sounds like
it doesn't make sense
well let's make sense of it tonight
we're gonna focus on the exact opposite
of an abortion clinic something called a
crisis pregnancy center facilities whose
primary purpose is to talk women out of
terminating a pregnancy something they
don't often make that clear instead
looking ads like this we're certain
where you make the decision about a
pregnancy that comes at a
less-than-perfect time get jelly on the
belly come to sunrise woman's clinic
early so I want to make it clear you
have problems with pro-life centers
running friendly act you find that
deceptive you find that deceptive as
opposed to ads from the benign benign
named Planned Parenthood we help you
find the birth control that's best for
you deliver life-saving preventive care
local cancer screening is an
authorization for your most personal
moments so you're prepared most
everything it all happens here I
Planned Parenthood every year we offer
trusted affordable care to 2.7 million
Americans so you're empowered to take
control of your biggest decisions and
lead your healthiest life Planned
Parenthood care no matter what unless
you don't want to kill the baby that's
true you gotta admit the luck that has
the branding down and he looks better
Slyke planned would you like to watch a
fetus be torn to pieces in 4k what you
do is you suck it up babies you chop
them up saw them up and then set them
down a tube we're gonna talk about this
could easily be considered false
advertising because it's called Planned
Parenthood it's not planned and you're
not a parent if it's going to be honest
advertising it sure he told oh wait oh
it's a kid we don't want to be parents
Kayla kill it kill it kill it that
should be the title of your ad it's not
planned you're not a parent next clip
one of the early pregnancy options that
you won't get at sunrise women's clinic
is an abortion but that can be hard to
do actually happens a lot with cpc's
take the center for pregnancy choices
and it was founded by a woman named
Barbara Bevers once you're inside her
CPC you'll find if you say you can kill
your baby and it'd be good for you
that's just deception I agree not true
it doesn't voice doesn't register with
reality mamas women are not made that
way women are made to protect them to
garden to to to die for their babies not
their babies to die for them holy Sh I
know right it's almost as bad as this
the abortionist uses this clamp to grasp
an arm or leg once he has a firm grip
the abortionist pulls hard in order to
tear the limb from the baby's body by
way one by one the rest of the limbs are
removed along with the intestines the
spine and the heart and lungs all right
it gets way worse they crush the head
and suck it down hood that is how
abortions are performed so you may take
someone who has a southerner and I
understand it if you take anyone who's
not from the south and you throw a
southern accent they're not gonna
believe a single thing that person says
her period you know hey listen this guy
is blue I think I think she's wrong
because of the way she said that what
do you think he was reacting to the fact
that she said that Mama's would actually
prefer to die for their babies and
babies for their mamas if that is I'm so
glad that you asked because the
empirical evidence would suggest she's
right the fact is women aren't built
that way study in Finland found that
women are possibly six times more likely
to commit suicide after an abortion okay
but how often do we hear about in the
animal kingdom when do take a mammal any
mammal including by the way human beings
yes okay when do women become most
aggressive when protecting their young
and we say it as though it sounds absurd
women are designed to give birth and
protect their young that is true
they aren't designed to have it chapped
up and suck down a tube it doesn't
matter how many times you say it what
the loath in your voice that's it we'll
get to that we'll get some more
statistics regarding abortion and
Planned Parenthood the services they
actually offer which John Oliver is
completely misleading about but that
let's start with that Marley was dead to
begin with let's go next clip there are
now 2,700 pregnancy centers in America
compared to less than 1,700 abortion
providers and the described as one
abortion clinic and thirty-eight crisis
pregnancy centers so here's a big
difference for two most crisis pregnancy
centers do not receive government
funding while Planned Parenthood
receives over half a billion dollars a
year now I am I'm personally attached
just those are some of the researchers
good my wife works at a crisis pregnancy
center she volunteers at a crisis
pregnancy center I know what they do
it's an entirely volunteer army they
have to do fundraising twice a year with
these banquets to make sure that they're
still in business and they compete
against a never-ending supply of federal
funding I know no money goes to
abortions but really that's the
moneymaker to Planned Parenthood which
is why they try to upsell you we'll get
to that later this is something that
people need to understand it doesn't by
the way you can have as many saves a
children with cleft palate centres as
you want if it's a volunteer center
planned parent receives it see that's a
pivotal difference by the way I thought
there are all just women's health
clinics why do it now why do we
differentiate now between Oh [ __ ]
providers and crisis put so many more
volunteer abortion doctor we need more
volunteer portion doctors step up to the
plate be a minute clip if you believe
abortion is immoral you are of course
allowed to set up a center dedicated to
convincing women about what is happening
with cpc's is that way too often we
with unplanned pregnancies or being
actively misled while trying to access
healthcare okay first off that's it's
not correct actually in a matter of fact
Planned Parenthood doesn't offer any
kind of educational programming if you
look at other than educating you on how
to be up sold to the abortion I find it
so fun if you haven't you want to open
up volunteer that's fine as long as you
provide all the services I want you to
provide she's bitching that these other
crisis pregnancy centers which provide
contraception which provide count you
know they provide consultants there they
provide counseling they provide they
help with nannying services they help
with single mothers option they even
help you by the way they're not all
conservative organizations they even
help you with with with welfare programs
and what you're eligible for he is
saying that well that's not really okay
because they don't provide the abortion
so let me make this clear
we're allowed to have our opinion
according to John Oliver and the
pro-abortion activists but we're already
paying by the way for your Planned
Parenthood with our tax dollars and now
these people are volunteering their time
and money to offer women other choices
and that's what you're upset about
they're double-secret paying paying with
taxes to Planned Parenthood then paying
with their dollars and volunteering
their time to provide alternatives this
is what pisses off the left are you
cpc's seem happy to have women confuse
them for abortion clinics just was
misleading anti-abortion activists watch
addressing a conference for one of the
largest CPC organizations we want to
appear neutral under said let me outside
the best call the best client you ever
get is one that thinks they're walking
into an abortion clinic okay those are
the best clients that could ever walk in
your door or call your center the ones
that think you provide abortions Wow yes
Wow indeed why would that be misleading
do you know oh yeah that's right you
weren't even know we've had Abby Johnson
on this show she's not an anti-abortion
activist she's a former director of a
Planned Parenthood
okay never he may never mentions it ever
and by the way she's talked about on
this show and in her book how to Planned
Parenthood she talked about how they
would try to sell women on abortions who
didn't even want them and they would
impose abortion quotas because it was
their most lucrative product so she in
the context here a former director at
planned parent
Hood said the best customer to walk into
a Planned Parenthood is someone who will
get an abortion who doesn't know that
they want an abortion and then context
the best person who would walk into our
crisis pregnancy center now which offers
everything but abortion contrast with
Planned Parenthood is someone who thinks
they want an abortion
that's the context former director
talking about context plantings next
clip the efforts to conceal their true
intent takes many forms starting with
the name many cpc's have the word choice
in their names like choices women's
center and while it should be easy to
get terrify any misconceptions with a
simple phone call that can be difficult
just listen to what happens when one
woman called a CPC for information and
keep in mind when you listen that the
center absolutely under no circumstances
ever provides abortions humanity that we
just so cpc's can lure women to meet
with them on false pretenses so that's
horrifying that's no it's not there's
nothing horrifying about by the way
what's misleading by using the word
choice when they're offering and
educating women and assisting with four
choices parenting adoption abstinence
contraception hmm what they mean when
they say pro-choice and that's why I say
you're an abortionist you're not
pro-choice
parenting adoption abstinence
contraception you say that we're anti
choice if we don't just provide the
fifth one the killing floor for the baby
well your anti choice well we're the
four choices not really we don't agree
with the abstinence okay so to you it's
less extreme to advocate abortion than
it is for abstinence I'm getting this
correct i'ma get this am I getting this
right because the star goes right
because you watch an episode of Glee
can't believe that this happens all the
time another marketing anyway they tell
you to click here for a price Oh call
one of our representatives so that we
can talk you into where the CPC actually
wanted to inform a woman here this
crisis pregnancy center of her option
all the or she went through with an
abortion this is something else too
again the left oh he says well I think
abortion should be limited in
it's horrible but you know if someone
really need well know right now this
person is just saying hey let's inform
you of your options yeah before she went
through with what we would all agree
even if it's not murder it's probably
not the optimal result so while we're on
the topic of false advertising how about
all those things that Planned Parenthood
does to trick people into coming into
their offices right like falsely
claiming they providing hammer grams hey
let's watch this this is great what's
gonna happen as a result of this if this
bill would ever becomes law millions
women in this country are gonna lose
their health care access not to abortion
services to basic family planning
you know mammograms I do not have
mammogram machines at our health centers
and we've never stated that we did it's
almost as though you're a pathological
sociopathic serial killer with babies
it's almost like you just said they
would lose basic health care services
like mammograms and then say we don't
provide manna brands we've never said
that we've had I don't understand don't
follow and this is why it's so important
to because they say basic health care
services whereas John Oliver just said
you know these amount of crushes
pregnancy centers and only these amount
of the bull shouldn't clinics because
that's what they do that's their hot
ticket item that's their Tickle Me Elmo
circa 1996 Sorna was a hot Christmas
item that you know exactly what I'm
talking about don't fact-check me a
turbo man
you're probably someone had an abortion
by the way also falsely advertising
prenatal care at Planned Parenthood they
can't help was that they're not capable
just as they don't have mammogram
machines I bet you a lot of people
watching this are surprised by that
because you've never heard it before
which brings us onto some more points
let's go next clip they often locate
themselves as close as possible to
abortion clinics this woman who we
aren't identifying speaks candidly about
the difficult decision she had to make
after becoming pregnant after a rape I
didn't want the baby it was a lot on my
soul eventually she decided to seek the
services of the Hartford GYN she
initially went for counseling and she
can remember how the clinic's neighbor
Hartford women's health
tried to offer unsolicited counsel as
well they was trying to tuck me over the
air then I was like you know like you
making me feel bad so now clearly that's
absolutely horrible
no it's not absolutely horrible what
okay first of a couple things that they
do they take an example who was raped
let's take them at their word here less
than 1% of abortions performed again why
for suspending women coming all the time
they know about contraception why
because it's 2018 it's not a lack of
education they just don't care they're
irresponsible and they often go in
thinking they want an abortion and then
they change their minds and we'll get to
that in a little bit the ultrasound
that's why Planned Parenthood charges up
charges for ultrasounds so unsolicited
advice is what they're talking about
something else even though they blur the
face I think we can all kind of agree
it's not races say seems as though she
might be a person of color people of
color aren't or doubt is likely to be
aborted today as they are to be born in
the United States that's by design by
Margaret Sanger notorious racist hated
the blacks so unsolicited advice these
clinics aren't assaulting women they're
offering them free information on a
pregnancy even with their story taking
the most extreme 1% take them at their
word rape victim right minority all they
had was she was tugging on me trying to
get me to go in like like and maybe it
made me feel bad bad I'm sorry I think
you're so out of touch that abortion is
the baseline that you think that's gonna
horrify your audience and most people
watch that kind of reasonable I don't
know next clip
I think Reese's can't get a physical
location right next to an abortion
clinic they have another trick up their
sleeve and that is buses that can
literally park outside and try and tempt
women in many cpc's operate mobile
clinics once cpc's have women inside
their building or van they can employ
every tactic in the book to try and get
them to change their mind every tactic
in the book like science and information
so here's the thing again the but keep
in mind this is why that the context
matters to these but volunteers right
volunteers most of these places these
are people who volunteered their time
and their money everyone knows what
Planned Parenthood is everyone knows
where to find them okay this is because
it's what's discussed when people talk
about women's healthcare they're talking
about Planned Parenthood when you have
people going out there was a sandra
fluke or Lena Dunham they talk about
Planned Parenthood they don't thought
most people don't actually know about
other crisis pregnancy centers that it's
really really hard to compete I'd like
if the government funded coke and you
had an alternative soda
but everyone knows what coke is yep and
it receives half a billion dollars in
funding so that's all but they think
Planned Parenthood is their only choice
no one talks about crisis Bernie Center
probably because they don't get that
kind of a funny so Oliver here is
complaining about them using their own
money to advertise that they can simply
find their clinic think about that for a
second the complaint now is not only do
these places provide these other
services not only are they informative
not only do they provide services the
Planned Parenthood does not provide but
they use they use vans I may have people
help with the SEO call next clip heart
beat international which has 1,400
affiliates in the US has this handbook
with suggested scripts featuring some
nonsense information it suggests telling
pregnant women that 35 percent of
suicidal behaviors among women may be
attributable to abortion which is bull
it also says that abortion almost
doubles the risk of breast cancer which
is also bull okay so a couple of things
here notice Oliver never dismisses he
dismisses he without really actually
providing any kind of a rebuttal right
ah now some of that information is wrong
and I'll get to that it's like yeah but
he's taking one example of a crisis
pregnancy center that provided
information that was inaccurate now it
wasn't as inaccurate as say telling
everyone before Congress that you
provide mammograms and then saying you
never said that you provided members
because you know the Machine it's not
that bad because the first thing about
suicidal behavior is actually correct
we're gonna go in a macro level it is
correct that comes from a study
published I think in the British Journal
of Psychiatry that found women's risk
for depression went up by 81% after
having an abortion and I think the there
was a direct association between suicide
and abortion which increased by about
35% so that was what now was misquoted
by this individual abortion individual
CDs CDC CPC yes then the staff they're
referring to I think it's a Chinese
meta-analysis 36 Studies on abortion for
breast cancer or increased the risk of
breast cancer to be fair that's not
really an accurate study to go by
showing a link there's no control group
between abortion and breast cancer so
the evidence isn't really clear on that
one but I and I want to give that one
but Oliver John Oliver didn't even
bother to look into it at all just like
the claims from
that's the difference between us and
people like in me research and we say
when yeah okay he's got he doesn't he
doesn't even look into it he has no clue
he reads the headlines and then says
that works next clip increasingly they
offer free ultrasounds which can sound
appealing it's free but often they're
not performing them so much in article 3
healthcare is a problem as for emotional
manipulation alright as for emotional
here's one thing when these crisis
pregnancy centers offer free
alternatives like women take them now
here's why he's still pissed off about
ultrasounds and why planned parent has
fought ultrasound laws right study found
that 78% of women chose to keep their
baby after seeing an ultrasound wow I
actually know where my wife Islanders
are crisis it's about an eighty six
percent rate of women keeping the baby
after having an ultrasound now that's
not throwing a Bible at their head it's
not Kerry's mom locking them in the
closet saying that God's given ORS it's
because he doesn't want to eat apple pie
it's not radical Christian
fundamentalism this is a study showing
that women look see a baby and 78% of
them decide that they want to keep it's
literally just reintroducing the
community plan that sucks it's not an
abstract choice anymore it's an actual
person and guess what without government
funding all they're doing is providing
an ultrasound for free now here's one
thing we talk often about wanting to
provide health care to the poorest among
us right Google free Planned Parenthood
ultrasound cost they don't get your
first appointment alone cost $150 this
is what they write when you search it it
says this covers lab work an ultrasound
and options counseling this fee will be
subtracted from the cost of your
procedure our fees start at 585 dollars
and increase depending on your distaste
no this is this is their sale there yes
car salesman [ __ ] just Google Planned
Parenthood ultrasound costs our fees
starting notice every 150 dollars versus
585 dollars that's where it starts again
read happy Johnson's book because she
talks about how much more money they do
with the up charges at Planned
Parenthood
they're assuming that you're going in
for an abortion yeah it's part it's if
you if you call now will absorb will
make these five easy payments only for
easy payments if you suck your baby down
a tube they right now this is what's
crazy to me about John Oliver
he's literally complaining about people
offering free health care voluntarily
while planned pair
charges these women for they turned him
$150 bundling it with abortion for a
service that they probably could do you
think that woman there made me feel bad
she did a for 150 dollars for an
ultrasound hmm we're talking about
common ground to you it's offensive to
provide a free ultrasound I don't think
we're gonna agree on much next clip for
all the lengths that cpc's will go to to
prevent abortions many of them don't do
a key thing that would really help that
and that's give women access to birth
control if you want fewer abortions you
should love birth control you should be
filling Pez dispensers with birth
control pills you should be giving
condoms out to trick-or-treaters and ru
D earrings out as hostess gifts birth
control should be your favorite thing in
the whole world and this is also
something I always spent funniest where
you hold a gun to someone's head and say
well if you if you don't want to murder
a baby you should provide free condoms
okay first off no that's not how that's
not how this works right well if you
don't want to go to prison for murder
then society you we need to provide free
apartments it's still a crime but here's
something else that you should note
there over 13,000 community health
centers most of them offer
contraceptives that women can visit if
they'd like those okay again the
workplace where I'm not where my wife
works ah they do I get abstinence
parenting adoption contraception these
are offered at most of these places not
all of them but that's why there are
options that's volunteer there are
options that's what's so absolutely
insane to me and by the way remember
remember that just to give you context
wonder you don't care if they provided
birth control or not you only care that
I'm not providing abortions remember
Hobby Lobby the outrage it happened
they're not providing they're not
providing women's health cares what they
said yeah what it really came down to is
not only did their insurance cover women
not only did their insurance in some
cases cover procedures women that they
didn't cover for men not only did they
cover 16 kinds of birth control the
problem was they didn't cover what they
thought as Christians were abort if
Achatz they covered all of those things
and 16 different kinds of birth control
and there were still protests up the
entire John Oliver argument it assumes
by the way that women are incapable of
making an informed choice he acted as
though the mere action of informing them
and off
than any other choice is an act of
violence or coercion he acts as though
anything other than the baseline of free
abortion on demand period is some kind
of an act of aggression against women
it's not this is an example of women who
are being offered free health care free
genuine women's health care as he
differentiated not just abortion clinics
but prenatal care all kinds of services
particularly expensive services like
ultrasounds that are not offered at
Planned Parenthood intifada soms on
oliver when you support women's health
care ii says we support free health care
well here's a place a crisis pregnancy
center and there are thousands Brosco to
here places that voluntarily offer
prenatal services ultrasounds adoptive
services as well as care for both the
child and the mother let's shut them
down due to the wrong point of view
you're not pro-choice
you're just an abortionist did you enjoy
this video here's the thing you wrote
you're here this is the end of it so we
don't care because you already watched
it but if you really didn't like it and
you want to justify it leave a comment
below telling us why you didn't like the
video and if you liked us let us know
and subscribe to the channel because
that lets the overlords at YouTube know
that you know what you're alright